the church of what's happening now is
presented by zeal
this show is brought to you by tis
distilled
distilled offers luxury grade denim
denim at an affordable price jeans that
would normally cost you hundreds start
at just seventy five dollars at
distilled dot com
now it's d
s t l d dot com d s t l d dot com
use codeword go slash joey to get 10 off
that's dstld.com
joey to get 10 off
this show is also brought to you by
indochino
go to indochino.com
right now and enter promo code church to
get any premium indochino suit for just
3.89
at
indochino.com and that's a promo code
church and don't forget shipping is
always free
oh [ __ ]
it's gonna be a good [ __ ] day
monday
february 13th i think who gives a [ __ ]
it's a beautiful day to be alive
the church of what's happening now
lee syed
my main man jorge mas de val
[Music]
and your uncle joey dears [ __ ]
every day you dirty [ __ ]
[Music]
i want your love
i need your love
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here my main man george
mazdival and my little jewish brother
lee syed what's happening gentlemen
how's it going sir it was a great
weekend great little [ __ ] weekend a
little calmly
uh what i do i hang out with the family
it's nice i had a couple weeks in a row
and then one week i shot a pilot that
whole week i was working i didn't see
him till sunday
and then i had to go to nashville so
this is really like and you know how
it's like bro you know how it's like you
get caught up sometimes then you say i'm
gonna go home next week and they contact
you for promotional week somewhere and
now you're on the road four weeks for
some guys they're like [ __ ] i don't have
to deal with my [ __ ]
but there's some dudes that truly i like
being at home probably you know 20 years
ago i didn't like being at home there
was no home you know i'm sorry i
couldn't wait till i got the [ __ ] out
now
i got something to be appreciative at
the house so you want to go home and
spend time with your family
i
like you were telling me you were gone
for a month before the cowboy fight for
a month
i would die yeah it sucked bro so long
i believe i was thinking of going to new
york uh before nyack and going to a nick
game then they lost to the lakers at
home there's no reason that the lakers
beat you at home on a tuesday night i
can't watch it so once that happened i
just made an excuse for myself i said
[ __ ] i have to go to new york for a
week now i'll just fly in wednesday
and [ __ ] do my show thursday friday
saturday i can't do it no more
george i can't do it no more dog i used
to leave here in november and come back
in april
and the whole time i'd be doing weekends
everywhere all over the country from
toronto to buffalo to miami for two
weeks that's what breaks me down i hate
travel i could go to one place stay in
one place but to bounce around like that
like two days here two days here two
days a year that [ __ ] sucks that's
that's they went through like a tour at
me and it was like three weeks
of four days in a row like for three
weeks and it's thursday friday saturday
sunday
and you got to travel all [ __ ] uh
four days
i can't do it no more dog yes i can
travel get to my destination the other
thing is i'm lazy i don't want to take
apart my sleep apnea machine
that's a pain to [ __ ] ass dog once
that sleep apnea machine comes out of
the bag that's where it [ __ ] stays i
don't want to [ __ ] around and to
you know pack it up again and take it
out the next day
but enough for this [ __ ] you can't
just get two of them get one for the
road yeah but even if you have one for
the road you still gotta break it down
every day that's my point
i have two of them i can leave one
there's one in the house i don't like
acting on the road
but you still gotta dismantle it put it
in the bag and that [ __ ] burns me the
[ __ ] up
so let's get back to basics here the
last time you came on the show i had
kind of an accident that night
i ate one too many [ __ ] stars you
know and uh
and we went a little off course here
which i don't sometimes it's fun
but you know i had a blast i don't know
i know we had a blast that night we
giggled our asses off
but the whole thing was i had things i
wanted to ask you and how you had come
up with these things and stuff
i asked you is
a to z
what made you raise your hand against
cowboy
and i said it on your show
you remember what a to z i said it on
your show so people know they're gonna
call me a prophet if you tuned in to the
last time i was here i said just what i
was going to do in the show and let's
break his will and then break his face
and it sounds nasty so that i'm still
talking like that but it's the truth
when it comes to fighting i like to
fight and i'm going to tell you what i'm
going to do so there's no coincidence
about it i'm going to kick your ass on
this certain date and i'm going to tell
you how i'm going to do it
now this is your health what number
fight 40
in the octagon uh
i don't i don't know the number 31
what's your record now 32 and 11. okay
32 11. that's [ __ ] that's 43 goddamn
fights
not to mention the 82 000 you had from
five to [ __ ] 14. yes sir i was
watching some of those tapes last time
they're good jesus christ
it's like
okay you had a bar somebody drops a
drink on your shirt you got a bit
slapping you throw two punches you go
outside you fight for a minute the cops
come it's over
you had to walk to this kid's house
you walk through the door like batman
you opened up the wooden gate and [ __ ]
you almost hit the chicken there was a
chicken in the yard and [ __ ] i mean
what the [ __ ]
now i watched that show the one that uh
your boy did the other director remember
he did his fourth movie is about
fighting
the guy that did uh miami
the [ __ ]
billy corbin
one of his movies was about fighting in
the black neighborhood where they rope
it up and [ __ ] dog fight dog fight i
watched that and it was interesting but
you're [ __ ] youtube [ __ ]
it's like you're there it's like you
don't even need 3d glasses you could
hear the punches and [ __ ] people talking
spanish what were you thinking
it's a fight that's what i was thinking
were you getting paid for those i was
betting we were betting you know um
people were betting there too as well
playing the best was going on and
it's a it's a way to make legal income
so no no tackling people just
a knee and once they go down you can't
uh armbar yeah once we got there we we
agreed no ground upon or none so i get
there and in the morning up from and to
tell me hey you can relax she's gonna
fight somebody else before you
i didn't understand why he would do that
but i was like he could do whatever he
wants okay so he fought some dude he
knocked him out like in 30 seconds a
minute i forget the exact time and i
come out and as soon as i'm coming out
everybody was
just screaming that i was gonna get
knocked out you know very similar now to
the cowboy fight everybody was yelling
you're gonna get killed look at this
skinny little guy who's gonna get
murdered
and uh i proved them wrong then you know
so i like the hostile territory it's
crazy because i thought about you before
you came on the show the last time and
yeah when i was a kid i got into
situations i got hit with a lunge box
but it was all while you were playing
and then like i remember i used to live
on 205 west 88th street if you ever go
to new york it's a nice apartment
building that's why i grew up when i
came from cuba that was the second place
where we lived but
i got into a fight with rudy the haitian
rudy the haitian lived downstairs rooted
in the haitian soundtrack
and me were good friends that every once
in a while we just beat the [ __ ] out of
each other
but my mother could handle it rudy's
father couldn't handle it and i would
tell mr rudy we're playing you know
basketball and he called me a [ __ ]
spec and i called him rudy the haitian
and all sudden we started smacking each
other and [ __ ] the next thing you know
one time his father took me
and held my arms
and he told rudy to hit him and rudy's
like no dad and he's like hit him rudy
i'm gonna [ __ ] throw you out so rudy
smacked me and he cracked my lip
and then rudy's father asked me where i
lived and i said 3a and he run he had me
by the neck and he knocked on the door
and my mother answered and the kitchen
was right behind the door and the guy
goes if your son ever touches my son
again i'm gonna come up here and beat
him up then i'm gonna beat you up and my
mom goes wait one second and she turned
around and she took the biggest knife
out of the rack bro
and she chased him up the [ __ ] steps
and then the lady and the cops came
and the lady next door came out and she
said she didn't see a knife
so the cops didn't arrest my mother
so [ __ ] uh the kid didn't see a knife
either only rudy's father but that
[ __ ] dad ran up those stairs
bro my mother was on him
my mother wasn't even dressed really she
was just [ __ ] uh it was like early in
the morning that poor dude had no idea
whose door no idea
no do it no don't even not on the
island's door well i mean uh
yeah jihad
they're not going to keep him on the
[ __ ] crazy so beside that there was
only one time in my life where i knew i
was gonna fight somebody
like at two o'clock we decided at 3 30
he came over and he beat the [ __ ] out of
me it was terrible i couldn't handle it
my head almost blew up thinking about
that i had to fight somebody in an hour
that's why i admire you guys because
but then i've had
fighters say to me dog how do you public
speak
it's [ __ ] terrible
i can't do it i have nervous breakdown
so it's kind of the same
walking on thin line for some people you
know what i'm saying yeah
for sure but you did great man you
you know it's really nice to see so i
thought that
dana had made a a statement about cowboy
about two years ago maybe 18 months ago
he says that he he's great with cowboy
but he doesn't know what cowboy is going
to show up i don't know who he thought
that he just looked you know he was flat
cam was a great fighter
who was an rda that he just looked
really flat that that's when dana made
the comment you know so i'm thinking to
myself look at [ __ ] uh
george has got him down he knew he won a
couple fights in a row he's bound to
lose it's a fight at home we all know
how tough it is to do anything at
[ __ ] home that's why i don't perform
in bananas
that's why i don't do that [ __ ] i always
perform in new york city where it's a
hike for them or a new brunswick where
it's a [ __ ] height for them but to do
something in my own backyard i'll never
do it i did it one time it was the
biggest mistake in my life i can't focus
man
i can't do crazy material because that's
the girl i was in the sixth grade with
we saw girl scout cookies i can't tell i
smoked crack and i was eating some
[ __ ] black chicks [ __ ] so i fall
apart at the seam so trust me there's
more there's more stories to this [ __ ] i
just eliminate the performing at home
that's it
i eliminated it in my backyard
no backyard appearances what happened
papa no backyard appearances no bro no
bro because it hurts too much on stage i
did it once in new york about five years
ago i played that thing
but i bombed i ate a box of dicks on
stage because i had kids in there from
the sixth grade
i didn't really want them and i was a
different kid in the sixth grade i was
catholic
i didn't smoke pot i wore tom mccann
shoes you know what i'm saying i played
with football i read comic books
now they come to see me i'm talking
about eating eight balls and [ __ ]
stabbing people and pedophiles kind of
embarrassing who's like
i mean have you thought about fighting
in miami did we do the half fights in
miami they haven't in a long time uh
they didn't do so well i think in the
past
so they haven't been i think too
inclined to come back i would prefer not
to fight miami because
everybody that you went to school with
the the lunch lady that hated you she's
calling you for tickets it's crazy you
know crazy yeah i'm maybe when the man
show was on whatever year the man show
was on
2004 2003
i had to do a sketch for the man show
but they wanted to shoot in miami
so while we were in miami that's why
they set up that way so joe could do the
ufc it was [ __ ] empty
but this was a whole different ufc this
was the guy from hawaii
the fatter guy i think the only guy in
the stadium was shaq
like shaq was like he had like six rows
to himself and [ __ ]
that's how [ __ ] dead it was
but what you do man is tough for a
[ __ ] living how old are you now
jordan 32 so if you're you're a young
man you're in your [ __ ] prime you got
another [ __ ] 10 years left
if you want to bang it out but
realistically like four or five you know
what i'm saying i got a good five mm
five million i thank god for the
reflexes i haven't been in too many wars
so i think i got the best
five years of my career now you know
i've been dropped it's not like i
haven't been dropped but i've never been
dropped in a fight twice or taken
sustained punishment you know that i got
beat up round after round you haven't
been knocked down in something like nine
years like knocked out or submitted and
it's crazy like you've lost some
decisions but i was looking at it it was
i don't remember right now but it was
something crazy like 2009 2005. it was
something weird like that it was a while
ago yeah you improve whatever you fight
george you feel yourself
improving you
know
it's it's not just what every fight is
with the opponent you know it's like
sometimes you're fighting certain dudes
or weak sauce dudes and you're like man
this is not where i should be you know i
kind of rise to the challenge if i'm
fighting a certain somebody and i know
this guy's good at
certain something i'ma turn it against
him you know i'm a cardio the cardio guy
i'm a wrestler the good wrestler cause
that's what i am in my mind i like to
beat guys in their own craft i knew i
was gonna be cowboy standing
with his own great weapons that he that
he uses to kick i was able to use that
kick against him because that's what i
like to do in fights you know so it just
depends on the opponent a lot of times
it's so wild how you have to
push yourself in this life and and
because i i don't get excited either
anymore just doing some stuff like when
i went up to
lee i figured out why i had so much
anxiety that night in wilbur you know
because of those reasons you want to
rise to the occasion
so my adrenaline just gets me all fired
the [ __ ] up and once i say two minutes
of material
i'm normal
you know my adrenaline gets so fired up
like so [ __ ] wound up in fighting i
think you gotta get blood for me i
always had to get points in the face one
time
once you get punched in the face you go
you got something
now you know you got to punch from him
you ain't going to go down now i know
where i am that was always my thing you
always got to get hit once or twice and
knocks you back into [ __ ] the
realville and you're like okay now i
know who i am let me breathe a little
bit get the blood pumping
boom boom boom
i i normally don't like it to ask about
current fights because we've got people
but this was kind of a big fight
what have you ever had a fight similar
to like derek brunson anderson silva
where
like you you were just so in shock of
seeing that personally like it just
seemed like like derek brunson just
couldn't believe for a few minutes that
he was in the ring with anderson like
have you had a situation similar to that
the
yeah the closest thing to it was when i
fought eve edwards i was very young in
my career and i looked up to eve's i had
seen a lot of his fights he had a dvd
going out of him knocking people's teeth
out it was crazy i forgot the name of
that dvd but uh he fought against aaron
riley twice in it
and um i had seen a couple of his fights
already and i knew he was so when i
fought him i was i was a little star
struck
how does it feel the first round's weird
you don't really want to hit him hard
enough no no no i was trying to kill him
since the start okay see how i was
trying to kill him i would [ __ ] fold
dog mentally i would fall i'm that type
of dude that i might think you're
studying all but i'm still going to try
to take your head off you know i knew
eaves was a beast
and i knew i couldn't respect him that's
the type of guy you you have to not give
him anything because he's a killer man
he was like one of the most
skilled fighters i think i find still to
this thing you know
who's the hardest punch in all your
fights that has rattled you because it's
not even about the hardest punch it's
where they get you with that punch yeah
because i've fought in some hard punches
and never got a hit off of me and then i
fight and wrestlers that weren't known
for hitting hard and and they got good
shots in on me um michael chaser rolled
my bell pretty good you know you
dropping pretty good in the first round
it was boom and a lot of times just like
a light switch and you're able to get
right back on
sometimes it takes a little longer to
turn the light switch on you know with
that one i kind of felt it was a good
shot you know you just breathe through
it you just keep moving man no matter
what happens
you take like a d it's like doing a
sprint you prepare to do a really long
spring you go
and just go whatever you got to do
because if a guy hit you again maybe you
go to sleep you know so you got to start
wrestling even harder or throwing more
punches you got to do something to get
that guy to stop whatever he's doing you
know
that's like the sprint right there the
ill sprint like the cops are chasing for
10 block sprint you know what a punch
that hard is to a comedian like saying
10 jokes and nobody even [ __ ] does
nothing
that's what shock you go into
like if i would do five minutes
you know 10 years ago maybe 12 years ago
if i would do five minutes and i wasn't
getting no laughs
it's like getting the punch to the head
because you got to breathe heavy up
there and [ __ ]
realize digging deep and see where this
next joke's going to come on you got to
set a pattern now and slow down
it's so weird the importance of slowing
down like just going okay
where the [ __ ] am i at [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
i put my hands in my pocket breathe a
few times and get this party started all
over and i see it all the time with
fighters
they're the kings of that [ __ ] yeah you
gotta be able to hit the reset button
and you gotta you gotta say
because when i'm fighting it's a voice
in spanish always talking to me in my
own head
and then i could just [ __ ] overdrive
you know you get hit and you get hurt
and you're like you hear that voice like
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy i'm gonna
[ __ ] him up you know in spanish i hear
that and then i just go bro you know i
feel that now man it's so weird when you
watch a fighter
for a few years or football player or a
boxer
and you see how all the pieces fall
together
that's always great to look at a
fighter's career or a musician
and see when all the pieces are falling
together that's not what's going on with
you right now there's a lot going on
there's a lot going on there's as going
on
you created a [ __ ] storm with this
[ __ ] and it's always great to see what
it takes you know what i'm saying to
create that storm you know
if you call somebody out you gotta
deliver the goods yeah
can you explain because to me when i
hear
calling out at first you might think
that you think the other person is a bad
fighter like you think you're going to
beat them but it's not that cerrone is a
bad like he's not a bad fighter he's
he's a he has some good skills like or
or do you not even think do you just
think they're terrible like what do you
think
because like because
to me i would want to acknowledge how
good the other person is because i don't
want them to be like oh well he just
beat cerrone well it's not just cerrone
like
well um from what i heard from like
several media sources and uh
i think i don't know if it was joe rogan
or somebody said that the best cowboy
they had seen was cowboy right now at
170 pounds
he was knocking people out and he was
taking people down he was writing them
out
i knew that that fight for me would be
easy and i knew he had a high ranking
number you know
that's why i say easy not just because
the fight will be easy but this journey
is is easy money
the easy money campaign but i knew that
that fight was going to be extra easy
man yeah what does easy money campaign
mean i see i keep seeing you tagging
them i can't i the game joey knows is
better than me is to be sold not told so
i can't i can't give it out like that
when we turn the cameras off i can tell
joey in person
but i can't tell everybody it's crazy
how strategic you have to be in this
business especially you have seen it you
know like i've said a thousand times
the longevity of a running back is three
[ __ ] years
you know we saw barry sanders and we saw
the dude from dallas
but in reality those guys come and
[ __ ] go we just don't see it
some of them get drafted hi go three
years you know in the ufc you have a
window and the formula is three fights
you know you win all three of those
first three fights
and then you start calling out
[ __ ] and you just keep climbing
little by little you know you look at
the guy you don't go from number 19 to
number one and call that dude out you
look at number 13. now you want to be
number 13 for a few months and then it's
so strategic you know what i'm saying
then
the two champions are gonna fight and
somebody breaks their hand and there you
are with a big dick and a [ __ ] bucket
full of yum yums
they call you and there you are it was
that [ __ ] easy to journey you know
you never know or for sure you never
know but you just gotta keep plugging
the [ __ ] away oh yeah i'm training
non-stop you know the ufc is kind of
interesting though because in other
sports it's it's
easily determined who's going to go to
the playoffs
but in the ufc
at that level there's some people who
you think are going to get the next shot
but it's never really there's no real
definite definite title shot usually
maybe now what the interim titles are
but with the
is that frustrating as a fighter like do
you feel like you should have gotten a
title shot or
i think um a lot of the the media
outlets are like
fake news much like our
commander-in-chief likes to say that
there's fake news i think there's a lot
more fake news in mma than there is in
the real world you know they got these
bogus rankings a lot of times like i
don't know who the [ __ ] be doing the
rankings you know when they do it
but
it's it's crazy i think a lot of it is a
popularity contest nowadays more well
let's pretend this is let's pretend this
is 155.
and you got rda you got uh
khabib
and you got tony ferguson and you got
the king of swing and you got four guys
and you three guys are going back and
forth wrestling and beating each other
up to determine who's gonna get the
irish kid right but guess what
the last two fights on the prelims i
knocked the [ __ ] out in the
first round and i mean one time the
mouthpiece went out of the [ __ ] day
and guess what the last time they put me
on a number three on the card i won by a
[ __ ] knockout and a kick to the head
and i call out
conor mcgregor
you know what i just came off three
dramatic [ __ ] wins
[ __ ] you three dudes you know that's
what it's entirely possible it's
entirely possible you know he's rising
quick and they decide that's the money
fight you don't know right now who's the
real money fight you know you know
there's 20 money fights right now yeah
there's 20 [ __ ] money fights now what
you got in the ufc is that
guess what man
and i'm not being out of line here
you took away my sponsorship money i'm
in that [ __ ] realm guess what i want
a money fight
i got if i win fights i got nothing
wrong by me asking for a money fight
put me in the ring with one of these
guys let me get a half a million or
three quarters of a million [ __ ]
dollars i need that yeah i just thought
i just fought seven times
for the small [ __ ] 30 g's or the
small 50 g's while everybody's getting
fat and flying to [ __ ] hawaii and
smoking you know what i'm saying you
look at the gates you look at different
[ __ ] things so i get that i did it
for years you know what they pay at the
comedy store on sunset 15
15
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday 15
if you do the main room you get 70 split
by 22 people
but during the week you get 15
am i frustrated no it got me to where i
am today
those six fights you had at the short 20
g's while everybody else was getting 200
000
what are you gonna [ __ ] do
but guess what i want now i fought my
six fights at 20 g's i got the fight of
the night bonus three times i got the
taste of blood let me get a [ __ ] one
of those one million things too let me
get some security for my family what
happens if i get kicked in the head and
i don't know how to [ __ ] spell
washington you know what i'm saying i
forgot how to spell washington how am i
gonna get a [ __ ] job but i'm 40. you
got to give me a little something you
know what i'm saying a little something
two or three of those fights in a row
you know michael bisping's looking for
it you know a bunch of those guys are
waiting for it i know the fight is
michael bisbee against your romero on
paper
but you know what michael bisping has
been there for 20 years he's been with
the ufc for a long time
he's he's got a knockout that's on every
knockout reel in america his eyes
dan henderson his [ __ ] eye porrecito
he lost the [ __ ] eye of this sport
you know what bro he's got two kids
let him get a money fight against gsp or
something like that one time you all
ain't going nowhere you're well lingo no
you're always getting stronger and
bigger every day you're always going the
other direction when you get to be 38
you can't see
your dick starts [ __ ] around your
piss smells funny but george up there
too he's like 38. he's like 38 but you
always got two more two or three more
years you know what i'm saying but these
guys are all
they're kind of entitled to it i can't
see me going into the ufc tomorrow
within two fights and saying i want a
million dollars
i can't give it to you you won two
fights kid
but let me see 16 18 fights
oh no please please chris weidman still
hears [ __ ] noises he can't hear new
chunks no more chris weidman that's the
loudest crack i ever heard in my [ __ ]
life he can't even be in the room with
his mic wife is making breakfast in the
morning chris weidman well what about uh
jared cannon here he fought last night
still does an faa job they said he does
10-hour shifts yeah right he just he
just found on the pay-per-view last
night
yeah he has a federal job
[Music]
and he's just like i'm not giving it up
well that's his insurance that's
probably his family's insurance i don't
know what his situation is
but you know that's the thing everybody
wants a money fight
you know why everybody wants to fight
conor may [ __ ] anderson still wants
to fight conor mcgregor
i heard [ __ ] sugar ray leonard wants
to fight should be you know everybody
wants to fight for sure everybody wants
to make 20 million dollars you know what
i'm saying but there's not a
there's not a lot of those fights but
you everybody wants one of them and
right now you've been to the ufc you
paid your dues
all the things you've been paying the
dudes have been paid i've been paid from
the [ __ ] backyard tonight from the
backyard than adam dude's been paid
outside the ufc that's what i mean like
a lot of dudes get to skip lines and
privileges
because they weren't the ultimate
fighter
or
they got a big fan base coming in and
you see him getting put on big cars and
getting pushed
and that's the [ __ ] that i'm like that's
cool you know but when it comes to the
ranking let's base that on the right
fighting ability
you know on who's beating who's up you
know
promote whoever you want to promote but
i just want to fight the best in the
world and this took until this long for
me to get this number by my name and i
didn't get good overnight i've been good
it's just that
i haven't been able to get these star
key matchups you know
how much bargaining power do you have
when you sign a contract i think because
i don't think the average fan and if you
can't talk about it that's fine i'm
asking you to tell your specific
contract but just can can you say i want
this specific i can i want more for a
fight or do you lock in how much you're
getting paid per fight for 10 fights i
don't know
i'll plead the fifth okay fair enough
your honor
it's a beautiful [ __ ] thing
you know listen man
i get pissed sometimes now
i get pissed when i go to a club now
sometimes
and they pay me on a percentage
and i look at the check and i look at
that same owner
who told me 20 years ago after i did the
longest yard that all he could pay me
his 800 for the week
and i want to [ __ ] punch the [ __ ] out
of him but at the same time
he gave me an opportunity to improve and
guess what
i beat the odds and i get him now you
know what i'm saying
so i understand i understand the fight
game i understand what happened i mean
do i support them now i like that i like
the fighters to make money they get
punched in the [ __ ] head this isn't a
[ __ ] job where you go in and staple
papers
and go home at the end of the day
you know
something might happen it's hard work
man
six [ __ ] days a week and you're sore
and you're eating advils what do you
think happens to your liver when you're
[ __ ] 60 and [ __ ]
it's it's tough [ __ ] life man
everybody wants to get paid but i don't
think at times people don't understand
the commitment they have to do to be
paid
you know i got it i had it over the
[ __ ] years listen i live so [ __ ]
six years ago i paid 600 for rent in
hollywood in the studio with my wife
you know what i'm saying but you stick
with this [ __ ] long enough and the whole
time i was making money all those years
i was just snorting it i was snorting
and smoking [ __ ] dope and eating like
an animal so you don't do [ __ ] dick
but
it's so weird how everybody gets into
stuff for money when i got into comedy i
didn't get into comedy for money bro not
at all i never thought about comedy i
never thought about money in comedy when
i would go when i would call you and you
say my club pays 50 bucks i would take
it
to me i knew how to pay my dues
i always [ __ ] knew that then one day
you wake up and you go you know what i'm
enough paying my [ __ ] doers
i ain't doing that [ __ ] no more and you
make a constant decision not to do it
and that's when the door opens up for
you
it's the people who say i'm not going to
do it no more then keep doing it then
they realize one day [ __ ] nobody's
paying me because you haven't made the
decision
after the strike in this town the movie
business dried up
bro i was submitting myself 20 times a
year for movies plus my agents would
submit me i was working all the [ __ ]
time then there was a strike in town
and everything disappeared so people
started contacting me for these youtube
[ __ ] movies
you know you got to bring your own
clothes or 100 a day that's the big one
in this town 100 a day
so that and you don't know it when you
book the movie but it's a night shoot
because they can't afford to pay for
locations
so everything's a night shoot in a rush
you gotta go to a strip club and shoot
at four in the [ __ ] morning
well i did like four of those things and
i said one day you know what i'm not
doing this no more and i kept getting
calls
kept getting calls kept getting calls
and i refused to do those [ __ ] things
and one day i got grudge match
did they pay me ah but at least i got a
big time [ __ ] movie i'm not wasting
my goddamn time it's not till i made a
constant decision
that that happened you know what i'm
saying
i then i see like when i was a comic
there was a lady who didn't [ __ ] like
me when i first started
for me to get back at her
i would do her rooms for free i would
call her up the day of the year i'm
gonna go down there
and do a guest spot because i knew that
it would just make me stronger that she
was a piece of [ __ ] anyway and i was
going to show her i was better than
[ __ ] she was then the club owners
would ask her how come you don't book
them and she would tell him some story
oh he does drugs i don't want to book
them whatever [ __ ] story she's dead
i'm still [ __ ] alive and taking like
a bad [ __ ] that i am
the moral of the story is it's like when
a fighter when you're home and you're
home and you see a fighter get up and go
i just want to fight i don't care what
they pay me you're like you [ __ ]
being the same thing with comedians
there's committee that's why when i
first got to the store one day i made
that remark i said
the place is packed they only give you
15 [ __ ] dollars
and more than man you said if you don't
want to be here take your name off the
[ __ ] list i put a [ __ ] map out
there
and i'll do a sign up list for you one
o'clock in the morning see how many
people sign up for you don't know how
lucky you are
but you always want to get what you
deserve also you know but for a while
you get a couple dicks in the ass and
that's
that's the way the [ __ ] ball bounces
even mike tyson got [ __ ] in the ass
i'm saying even mike tyson
somewhere along the line
something happens that's where you got
to watch your back like a [ __ ]
you know all day what's up lee syed how
you feeling
i'm feeling better than uh than the last
last week which was fun though but uh
i'm feeling good man i had a i won on
the anderson silva bat i had a good
night last night you wouldn't play
blackjack friday night yeah oh my god
yeah i had a i thought this how'd you
get how'd you get rid of the wife that
night what did you do on friday night
how did you get rid of him i just she
went to spend some time with her cousin
they watch some
think i'm never going to get cable
because that means i don't have to watch
the reality tv she goes to her mom's
house to watch reality tv perfect so i'm
just never going to get one that's
forgotten on netflix
yeah i mean that's all i would watch
anywhere in the program yeah [ __ ]
i don't and it's so sad i don't watch
sportscenter at all anymore but uh yeah
i had so much
i really think and now someone can just
steal it
i really think it'd be a great like
almost like a cheer show but just in in
a casino
i think casinos i love it
i don't know this casino you go to
ventura correct yeah this is what the
they're all they've always been very
nice to me there it's just the opposite
of vegas how big is it
it's like in between
a car dealership and an rv dealership
it's probably the size of like a big
warehouse they have a restaurant
like they have mostly poker tables but
they have baccarat and uh like two or
three blackjack tables in the back booze
yeah how far is it from here an hour
and the reason why i like it is they
don't do collection because for whatever
reason in california that you have to
pay a dollar per
100
your if you bet 100 you have to bet a
dollar to play your hand in blackjack
and this one they have a company that
pays for you
so why don't you go down here to these
places 20 minutes away downtown huawei
used to go gamble those got this
i don't know anywhere to one like
there's commerce but they have the
collection
uh hollywood park has a collection um
i've never been to morongo or something
like that but i can't almost got good
chinese food playing i've i've been to
commerce a few times so a commerce was
kind of scary
i did commerce when i first moved i i
wasn't even living here yet i was here i
was here like 21. you walk in the
comments you know the yakuza lives and
then
so does the [ __ ] ming dynasty so
there's a bunch of filipinos any day
that's day is about to go off a few
mexicans every time you go in there you
won't look around you're like
but we did comedy there for years
they did comedy there i used to go in
there every thursday
they gave me like 50 bucks you went a
little diner and then i gave you a free
meal i i [ __ ] milked that you know
every thursday bro it's the same [ __ ] i
never ate there i've never i've only
done i did that one for the first time
and uh what is it called inventorial but
commerce was kind of the first time i
ever played blackjack was in commerce
and i had this lady yell at me because
she was spitting three hands of a
hundred dollars a hand she was
professional was she asian no she was
black she was about black women don't
mess around either asian asian women are
kind of uh quiet they'll be quiet and
hate you but black women will yell at
you at the table
at least this one did you gamble jordan
a [ __ ] ton yes what do you gamble poker
poker okay see the casinos in miami
casinos yeah in miami
all over south florida
and how big are they compared to this is
how [ __ ] [ __ ] i am they're big i
know nothing about this that's a hard
rock what am i saying i know about the
magic city casino but i thought that was
just an isolated incident
no we got magic city we got mikasuki we
got hialeah the hard rock coconut creek
the isles casino
i know marcus i'm a degenerate
so yeah
what type of cards do you play like what
type of [ __ ] blackjack do you play no
i don't play blackjack i play poker okay
that's it how long does it take you to
learn poker because that's one that
everyone says i have to learn
i started playing when i was like 15.
house games all the way up till i was
like 22 23 and then
from 23 until now i've been at the
casinos or no like as soon as i was uh
19 i started going to the casinos but
not regularly
how great is it when you win
how great is that feeling it's awesome
i've made good money in poker in vegas
and in
tournaments in florida
so it's paid off so you're a tournament
guy also i could play tournaments i used
to do them a lot more i don't have time
with the kids is a
a two three day tournament
i can't afford to be that many days you
know so i mainly play cash now now two
three day tournament you stay there the
whole time no sleep
no no you get to go home and sleep it's
like eight hours some of them it depends
a one day tournament could last
eight hours ten hours four hours if it's
if it's like a quicker format when i was
a kid bro i lived on this block
when my mother died before my mother
died i'm giving out terrorists but i
used to live i used the benders lived on
39th street whatever the [ __ ] that
street
they were like you know six families
that got together
every friday night
and they would cook for the weekend for
the kids they'd leave money out for the
kids
these [ __ ] would play cards
from friday night straight till sunday
morning bro no drugs
holy [ __ ] no drugs coffee cooking food
coffee lay down for an hour and get up
and play [ __ ] poker if you're losing
you stay up the whole time i
i don't have patience no more choices i
don't even know how to play poke i don't
know i know how to play blackjack vegas
dominoes how about dominoes vaguely
anymore i was more when i was a kid i
played at the house they played at the
bar
you know but it wasn't like something
that i went you know when i got locked
up
i played with some of the black dudes
from time to time you know i didn't know
how to gamble on or nothing i don't know
about this that's my second sport
dominoes
more than the polka
i go on streak see i got like a domino
partner which is my brother he's not
around now so we don't play that much
together you play it with the team and
me you know
me and him know how to make the money
you know what do you play dominoes
oh man everybody plays dominoes
in the houses you go to the domino park
but those are like the og dudes of the
city it's just old cuban men that are
calculators you don't put your money
ever up against those guys because you
just lose you know that's next level
[ __ ] but like at the family parties and
stuff i'm the champ you know how much
are you betting on dominoes
well it'll be
like like joy was just saying we'll go
to like a cookout on friday however many
family and friends
everybody will pay in 20 dollars you
have like 25 people that'll do that
winner take all or second place gets
their money back winner takes the rest
okay that's that i thought you were
putting like a thousand dollars a game
no if you want you can't there's people
to take it that seriously you could find
it and put a thousand dollars up on
dominoes
yeah
you know it's so weird i sport gamble
for like a year i took a beating
and i just never had no interest in
gambling i worked too hard to give my
money to a [ __ ] bookie
[ __ ] that [ __ ] they used to break my
heart when i had to meet that
[ __ ] on thursdays and give him
200 [ __ ] dollars he used to kill me
inside duck kill me
so i said [ __ ] i just won't gamble
i can't handle it if i'm stealing and
selling drugs i'll give you whatever you
want on thursday you know what i'm
saying but if i got to get up and work
for it in the morning and do comedy and
[ __ ] i can't get
i'm saving the game is that the most
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah that's the most
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
if i was selling coke oh yeah i gamble
if i was robbing houses still dropping
drug deals oh i'll gamble that money
away i'm the quickest do it i bet the
super bowl next year i'm one of those
[ __ ]
but
if i gotta get up and work for it [ __ ] i
can get with my [ __ ] money jack you
just suck my dick i'll gamble on wheat
that's it how crazy i'm i set up a bank
account i'm saving i would like it just
just to have a little
thing i can draw from so i don't go
crazy and
[ __ ] lose my apartment or anything so
you have a gambling bank account yeah
i'm not drawing from it but i'm saving
i'm saving up so i can do another one of
those little big at the end of the year
vegas trips and i want to like i would
just like to go and be able to sit down
at the 25 table and like
pay him like 500 bucks and not like not
worry about it and you're not going to
come home after the first this guy
always taps out doug well because i
always keep you know
this guy gets there at seven
he's got a room for two days by 12 he's
driving back
they broke him that happened twice they
broke them they just broke them they
broke his will he comes back twice yeah
oh yeah you gotta milk it slow you got
them getting better now why don't you
practice at these casinos once a week go
down on thursday nights when i'm gone
and play cards at [ __ ] kawanga
whatever but whatever the [ __ ] name
of this players cause you know yeah just
tell mama from now on on thursdays i'm
playing cards
yeah well every man has a card tonight
that's true every man has a card you
want to be good at cards lee you can't
show up in vegas
once every six months yeah right yeah
and play [ __ ] cards this is this is
the eighth discussion we've had about
you like the gamble yeah if i i was
thinking that's just in the culture you
know you gotta like no i love dude if i
was saying that's in the mandatory
standard contract you got like two
nights a week that are just for you
minimum
minimum starting rights just for you
if you want to manage your words this is
what you gotta do you gotta go somewhere
on thursday now do they play blackjack
and mentor yeah so you know thursday
nights i'm from out of town
you leave at five you have a nice dinner
by yourself you bring a couple stars you
go to the small table and you learn
everything you can
yeah just get under your belt every time
you go you go to lose after five hours
that's like me going to jiu jitsu once a
month and getting tapped out and not
coming back for a month you're not gonna
learn nothing right yeah if you're gonna
learn how to play cards that's why you
lose all the time because you're rusty
because i make mistakes i always have
there's always like one hand that i mess
up on pick a night pick a [ __ ] night
yeah every week one of those can uh what
do you get those consulting things yeah
that goes to you get your gambling money
what happens if the isis comes tomorrow
what good is that gambling fun gonna do
for you nothing
that gambling funny gonna do nothing and
you like going to those weird places
like korea town you're gonna get shot
down there one day so why are you
putting money away for
take that money every week to consult
the money and take two consultings and
go up to this is your money that nobody
knows about and nobody should know about
until i said it on the podcast but
you know what i'm saying like an [ __ ]
rat that i am
this is if you want to play cuz this is
the problem you want to play we've had
this discussion you go you get your
child for cheap hotel yeah you know and
then you come back the time i i staked
you twice you were kissing no the only
i'm surprised anderson silver didn't
lose yesterday when i found out you're
better well as soon as i saw it on
twitter i go poor [ __ ] anderson
he's going down you're the kiss of death
but you're good at sports but if you i
just thought about it if you practice
this blackjack once a week yeah maybe i
get better yeah you get better you get
the consulting nobody knows about you
take two of them you hop in your car at
five before the traffic hits you go up
they got a nice stake like a doctor
and you play some blackjack you drink
some coffee you eat a star or two yeah
no that's right that's right they don't
know
they got a hotel up there
they have like a motel
but it's not like literally an hour it's
literally no i'm just saying for that
reason i'm saying if you want to go
outside and take a nap and maybe pull
your dick and take a shower and go back
downstairs and get more money oh yeah i
could yeah no i totally would yeah but
for 69 if you want a thousand
69 ain't gonna put a dent in your
[ __ ] g note you bring a little
suitcase you get to the hotel next door
you wash your [ __ ] you watch an episode
of [ __ ] law and order you scrape your
[ __ ] you take half the money put it
away and you take the other envelope
downstairs and now you're ready for
round two you got to take a nap when you
gamble it well how do you win a [ __ ]
one-armed bandit i don't know what that
is the one-on-bend at the [ __ ] slot
machine how do you let the slot machine
play i don't know you have to sit there
okay the people who win the big [ __ ]
money they sit there
and they aren't it they pull they pull a
[ __ ] uh
uh george mazda bar they count the odds
they go against the odds they put
quarters in for an hour then they throw
three quarters in for [ __ ] 20 minutes
and they don't tweet then they just
throw quarters in there but the whole
time they're getting the wheel of
fortune and they're milking that
motherfucker's titties and you're
sucking the titties and you're
finger-banging a little sudden wheel of
fortune you've been there for six
[ __ ] hours that machine's as warm as
it's gonna be eventually it's gonna spit
out a [ __ ] golden retriever here bam
you get your 50 g's and you go to your
room nobody sticks around long enough
with the slot machine
because they lose their money all in one
[ __ ] [ __ ] well when you go to the
casinos though the not to the people who
stay they're all there the the
older women and men who just they bang
it out oh yeah and then if they go to
vegas ten times a year they make money
seven times
guaranteed they got three weekends they
lose what maybe two three hundred how
much can they possibly save up they're
gonna check on the first
right
and i i don't know i know i know it's
i'm not supposed to like it losing money
but but
i'm a shy person
i love i love the whole part of game i
love everything about it i love being at
the table and high-fiving i love telling
people good luck when we wish good luck
we have a black hoping for a blackjack
you hit the table i get crazy i like i
like it it's it's a
it's a whole atmosphere
that it's
it's like a little party it's when you
get going late at night with a blackjack
table
there's nothing more fun when everyone
at the table is winning when the
dealer's rooting for a bust and any bus
and and then
especially if you're at like one of the
weirder like one of the casinos that has
a bust side bet where you can bet that
the the
dealer's gonna bust and like so if you
have like a seven i was at a table
at ventura and this happened because i
don't make that bet because it scares me
these people made like a fifty dollar
bet had like a seven card bust
which paid something crazy like eighteen
to one eight eight to one they got at
450 dollars just off of that person
busting
they were high fiving buying drinks
tipping people it's there's nothing more
fun than me i don't know there was
splurging at the table free drinks for
everybody
well but and in vegas it's uh
vegas is fun
because the uh
the dealers will help you a little bit
these dealers were a little bit more so
there was a almost i had to leave i left
because there was almost a fight
at the table another fight but the
dealer just was kind of at almost
yelling at one of the uh people like he
just wouldn't
the who was an [ __ ] he said uh i wish
the other deal was over here and the and
the dealer just went he was like why are
you saying that to me i'm right here
and then the kid just wasn't
he uh he didn't expect to get talked
back to and i like i like that stuff too
it's very nice
i'm happy you like that stuff you like
going jumping up and down and [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you gotta get yourself some big
[ __ ] black chicken put those titties
in your face
while you're blackjack and you always
leave that out [ __ ] oh i don't have it i
like high fiving what the [ __ ] are you
talking about [ __ ] yeah it's fun
i don't know it's like i gotta deal with
i'm like that is crazy he didn't say i
like winning money because i'm in and
out i [ __ ] see that's a problem i'm
not into completely obviously i don't
want to i hate when somebody recognizes
me and just starts talking to other than
i'm like yo
oh actually i haven't had that no one's
no one's ever recognized me at a table
that might get weird
well nothing well just because it said
no they might only get the south point i
saw people bothering you really i mean
they would say hi but saying hi is fine
but if it just put money on the table i
could see i would be weird
but see my issue is i'll be up and then
i won't leave and i lose all my money
that's everybody's issue
that's not just yours i don't feel bad i
[ __ ] did what you did i got yelled at
1995 at the mirage
i had no idea what i was doing oh yeah
like they get angry at a couple bumps in
me i walked up to that blackjack table
just to start it was like a 10 table
every year i worked for a guy that would
take you to vegas in february
as part of your package it was i worked
for a gambling service
so he was good friends with fred wynn
whatever the wind the guy that was that
and the guy would put us up in the
mirage and then we'd have dinner up in
wyn's office
it wasn't bad you went for three days he
gave you an allowance
which i didn't gamble i just know to
cook with it
you know that's the only time i went to
a strip club in vegas i've not been in a
strip club since 1995.
wow 14 of us that is discipline my
brother i just didn't have use for it
that's discipline i didn't have use for
it i want to suck your [ __ ] and suck
your titties and finger you i don't want
to sit there and throw dollars on you
like a half a day oh no no no i'm too
old yeah no miami you could do that oh
yeah miami they're disgusting animals
they're there it's crazy it's it's
different how like others it's crazy see
when i was younger strip clubs i'm not
saying i want to put my my penis in here
i'm going to grab your titties i'm like
i got a couple drinks in me show me that
monkey you know what i'm saying bend
over do something speak to me oh
toothless one
something jack
so i didn't want to
i don't know
i didn't really
that was it in 95 for me
that's the shaolin monk like discipline
it was creepy
it was a ton of guys you know like there
was just too many guys
and the [ __ ] up thing it was
listen when you walk into a strip club
as a man but did you watch the weekend
no i went during the week and it was
[ __ ] packed
this is 1995
yeah 1995 with 14 guys from a sports
betting office you know
six of us were crazy we had a package
maybe i had weed in the room you know
you didn't have to do [ __ ] with them all
day but the guy knew i was a little
crazy and i made him feel better if i if
i tagged along with him
so i went to the strip club and
i don't know that
i used to go to striply when i was
younger in jersey where chicks used to
sit on a bottle
and then when i was a comedian when i
first started doing comedy i went to a
strip club in toronto that wasn't bad
but besides that they've never really
tickled my fantasy like i had to go down
and have a good time
and that time in vegas i sat there for a
little while
and i got a lap dance and nothing
happened they wouldn't even let me touch
their tits or whatever you know
and i was like why am i sitting here i'm
a grown [ __ ] man you know
where was the setting this is one of
those big clubs where you know you're
supposed to go and have a good time and
i know i'm wrapped a little too tight
but it was funny because i sat at the
table with a bunch of dudes
and the girl was dancing first of all i
never forget she had a white head on her
ass and they kept driving me crazy like
how do you go to work with a white hill
on your ass but that's not the issue
here right we're sitting there
and something happened with a girl bent
over and i made a noise
like yeah something like a cuban would
do you know it was like a rica
and she [ __ ] got insulted
like what you know i'm saying like i
didn't say nothing bad i didn't
i saw like jesus i said what like that
and she came home and she's like that's
so polite
[ __ ] okay
so i was like what the [ __ ] am i doing
in here so i've never really been to a
strip club in vegas nor do i want to go
on top of that there was a bunch of
dudes and half of them were dressed up
like they were going on a date like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
like they were dressed up like like that
this is real
this was real for them and i'm like i
can't be any a dog i can't i can't do it
so i just don't go hey listen different
strokes with different folks if you look
at me you think i like dirty hookers and
strip clubs not at all
i'm never at the comedy store i've never
been to
crazy girls or the other one i went
outside crazy girls to buy coke my
armenian dealer used to meet me over
there saturday nights but i never went
in crazy girls
just not my cup of tea can you believe
that bro
i don't blame you i'm a horny dog i'm a
horny dude i got desires we all got
[ __ ] desires where's tony
bennett g
um
oh
i'm gonna give some shout outs here to
my man justin curlette
jalal
salam
james edward trolls
sleeve choke bjj
my man d in colorado
darva mcginnis
devon holmes
walter white
and ryan
slay i don't know what the [ __ ] i love
you [ __ ] thank you for being bad
[ __ ] and always supporting us
here
what's going on g money
you plugging in phones you sending morse
codes what the [ __ ] is going on here
tonight i gotta ask you some questions
here your children know what you do
my children love what i do they watch
you fight they love it they they watch
my two years watching you know
the two-year-old yeah
he watches you bobby bobby bobby while
the tv's playing he goes nuts he knows
when it's me
how you put the videos on for him and
everything yeah they watch it live they
come watch your train oh yeah looking
tremendous [ __ ] tremendous
they know what i do i couldn't imagine
george's mother when i was watching that
fight i'm watching
and it's funny because
you know i'm a fan of the sport and i'm
a fan of people it's till i meet you
but it's a different game
if i meet a fighter and i kind of like
him now i don't want to see him play
normal
i get all guilty and [ __ ] like i don't
want to watch him fight though i'll
check and see who won later on i was
thinking about that when you were
following cowboy
i'm like i really don't want to say this
[ __ ] but i know what is that i do want
to say this
and before i could think and turn it off
the fight was over
so it was freaking beautiful yeah once i
fall in love with something oh my god i
really don't want to see them fight down
yeah when there's somebody closest yeah
yeah it kind of bothers me i get more
nervous with my friends my teammates
yeah i'm fighting this thing myself you
know me too it's kind of weird it's out
of your hands you know so it's like
you know it's different like i would go
to anderson silver fights and so i
started talking to him one day with that
suarez and
i noticed how nice he was then when i
would see him we chitchat and one day
said i told rogan i don't like a little
more and this is so fine it's like what
i like him too much dog
i like him too much i don't want to see
him fight
he's a beast man
still doing what he's doing at this age
42 years old is he 42 i think right
42-41
i thought he was 39. he's been on top
for so long
even before the ufc you know if you had
that situation would you still fight
well he pulled this one out
yeah i don't know how many fights he's
got left in the contract maybe two more
maybe a couple more he's 41
he's 40 turning 42 in april
i had so many wars so many great fights
and he was on the on top of the world
before the ufc was kicking ass and
trudeau
he's been he's one of the greatest i
think in the sport he's the one that
made me watch the ufc again
like i watched the forrest griffin thing
and that was great
but when i saw anderson silva beat up
levin
i i that was it i was sold i was sold i
became a real fan and watched all his
fights the precision yeah just
interesting that [ __ ] veto about
[ __ ] kick that steven seagal showed
him
what the [ __ ] steven seagal he stopped
rushing man he's in russia is he i saw
that he was like a russian uh citizen
now
yeah so he's the only one that left
after trump got elected no no i don't i
don't think he had nothing to do okay
i thought he was the only one that left
no no i think they fought all the people
who talk [ __ ] he's the only one that
left you [ __ ] should all be
ashamed of yourself
yeah he was doing something steven cigar
he was at all the [ __ ] ufc's for a
while he had like a big sponsorship in
russia he became like a the first dual
citizenship something i i read something
then i forgot it because i get punched
in the head too much but
i saw some of that nature you know
he's still making movies i know i've got
if you look at his imdb
he's made a hundred movies that you've
never even heard of
because he probably just does foreign
distribution they don't even put him on
and he makes so many movies they don't
even put them up they match them with
everybody
dmx bmx
jj mcland they've hooked him up tom
arnold
they've had him with everybody except
the [ __ ] dead people
like they've hooked him up with
everybody at this point if you imdb him
about a year ago
he's made so many [ __ ] movies
i don't think he's making any money i
think like he probably had like a tax
lien or something he did something he
beat up keller lebron he did something
that [ __ ] dude
he has 55 actor credits and
49 producer credits
yeah yeah that means they give them they
give them the producer because they
can't pay without listen stephen you're
not selling tickets here's three movies
that have been com either announced
completed or in pre-production
four
years hey dawg he works a lot more than
me i ain't goofing on him i'm just
saying that after a while like dean kane
those type of guys nobody's watching
movies for them no more they still work
all the time but the only way they can
really make money
they get what what sag will do is say
okay
so it's a hunger all day movie we're
gonna give you 200 a day 250 that's the
most we give you for those
but we'll make your producer
if the movie makes any money you get a
little [ __ ] backend
so that's smart like i was doing those
dean kane ones those were 100 all day
movies for [ __ ] the disney channel
though
but after the first one then they had to
pay us
they were still 100 a day but they would
give us bonus money
at the end of the shooting under the
table like that's an envelope nobody
[ __ ] saw tremendous no commission no
nothing
nobody saw nothing every year they gave
you a raise it was tremendous they
haven't called in two years so i guess
that's the end of my [ __ ] dog saving
career you know what i'm saying the dog
saved america the dog saved christmas
the joggers saved easter the dog that
saved christmas day
it was an education doing those bro to
do six [ __ ] movies like that with a
[ __ ] animal you have no idea dog you
have no idea what it is to shoot a
[ __ ] movie with an animal and what a
mistake it is until you're [ __ ] doing
it and the dog ain't paying attention
because it was a b movie so they
couldn't get smart animals they got
these stupid animals that they were just
taking like a gamble with like let's see
if tiffy will work today you know what
i'm saying it was like one of the
producers oh it was [ __ ] terrible if
you watch those movies you could hear
like that we had what's the chick that
caused a bunch of trouble that sunk dick
on tape hilton
paris she was the voice of chihuahua one
year
i mean it was [ __ ] god awful
but i tell you what it was an education
they called me when they made me
audition i auditioned i got to roll the
first movie we shot up here and if you
watched the movie like the first few
days it was like six days to shoot the
movie but you shot all day the last day
they did a scene
where the dog attacks us and the
chandelier falls on us
and it's me and dean kane then you get
cut
and he's getting off on top of me and
also my [ __ ] fart right in his face
it's on the [ __ ] movie if you watch
the outtakes at the end
so they called me back for the second
one i'll tell you what
all those movies it was an education
like i said and i'm really proud that
they use me and i see them all the time
they don't pay me no residuals they're
[ __ ] thieves a couple people took him
to court already because every once in a
while i got a check and i got a letter
with it saying that you know these are
back residuals you got old everybody
sued the [ __ ] company they don't want
to pay receivables
what a [ __ ] up career it is to be in
hollywood they don't want to pay your
[ __ ] residuals you know how many
snowballs i jumped off of the one movie
we shot in colorado but how many [ __ ]
times i fell in the snow those were real
falls i was my own stunt man there was
no stun double i got out of the [ __ ]
day that we think there's a there's
another me out there there's no [ __ ]
other me out there
[ __ ] i was my own stunt double for
100 a day
then they called me like for the fourth
one and i just had knee surgery
i told him i said listen i'll do it but
there ain't no jumping off buildings
there ain't no crazy [ __ ] there ain't no
running first day i get to this
motherfucker's like you gotta run up the
hill i go what i [ __ ] tell you on the
phone i ain't running up the [ __ ]
hills you better put me on roller skates
and pull me with your teeth [ __ ]
by the end of the movie i tormented him
so much he just quit he never directed
one of those dog movies again his name
was mike pfeiffer he's like a born again
christian now he got out of the movie
business he was terrible changed his
life that bad day
out of movies i think born again
christian oh please well he was always
like a half a born again christian he
was almost like a half a fan but you
retired him like from the movie circle
out you know what i haven't seen him but
he hasn't directed those movies anymore
he hasn't directed them since that time
i told them off on the way up the hill
how much did you torture that guy that
he quit his profession
bo when you shoot those [ __ ] movies
they drive you crazy so i gotta drive if
i know that driving
i love torturing people but he was
torturing me this guy
you know how you torture me
by doing the same scene 10 times and
it's perfect after the third scene
nothing bothers me more than that and i
tolerate it for a little while and i
[ __ ] play it and nothing bothers me
more when somebody asks you
if you could do something and you say no
and then they ask you again
nothing bothers me more than that
nothing and people like doing that in
the movie business you know what i'm
saying
in the longest yard there's a scene
where we all jump in the water
you ever see the movie
we all jump in the [ __ ] pond we mud
right in the mud
when we got to that morning bro there
was smoke coming out of our [ __ ]
breath
and nellie was like
i gotta sing this weekend [ __ ]
i got three [ __ ] shows and i
get paid i ain't [ __ ] jumping in
there
you know what man we [ __ ] jumped in
what the [ __ ] we got him to jump in
they asked us do you want stuntman no
nobody used to stop man and it was
tremendous we only had to do it we did
it in one tank
one [ __ ] thing we did it i like that
[ __ ] i know that's it we got it
you do these movies that are 100 a day
the director thinks he's [ __ ] fellini
you're following me when you work with
it's like we were talking about fighters
the other day you never hear about ufc
fighters get into brawls in the street
because i could call george a thousand
things
george is so secure
in what he could do that he won't even
say nothing back to me
and he'll walk away i can say [ __ ] about
his family but georgia just walk away
you know
because they're a [ __ ] professional
but when you work with a high level
director
they're cool
like
the spider-man 2 dude how many times do
you think we shot that spider-man scene
maybe once or twice move on
dnmb camera a camera d camera i got it
it's somewhere in here we got it let's
move on
but when you shoot with a less
experienced director for him to show you
his balls that's what they do to you
george
they [ __ ] with you a little bit because
they're not that guy
they're not spielberg they're not that
[ __ ] guy trust me dog i've done 20 of
those [ __ ] movies and about 10 of
them i've had a pool of directors
signing a look oh
don't don't even think about it don't
even think about asking you ask that
and you have to do that if not it's like
anything else in your life
they'll just keep snowballing
well it's not always true but how many
times did you have a new teacher like a
teacher who had just come out of college
and they were hard ass and then you had
a teacher who'd been there for 30 years
and they were cool as [ __ ] yeah that
seemed [ __ ] interesting yeah that's
it and the guy that was a hard ass is
getting [ __ ] grown at him right he's
getting [ __ ] up then bro i went to a
school called mckinley
listen my in my jurisdiction in north
bergen there was probably nine no
kennedy mckinley franklin lincoln robert
fulton horace mann there were six
grammar schools
everybody knew lincoln if you were on
the third floor
you were damaged goods
you know what i'm saying something was
wrong with you there was no medication
in those days they just put you on the
third floor and they took their chances
i'm sure you were really nice to the
third kids no i didn't go to lincoln i
didn't go to lincoln they put them on
the third floor and they hope they jump
out a window you know what i'm saying
that's what they put them on the third
floor they left the windows open those
kids a little bit
look around look at what i'm saying they
were all [ __ ] up they would go to
basketball games and change
like that's how [ __ ] up lincoln was
though they would not go and cheat yes
they would they were [ __ ] savages
when i was in the 8th and 7th grade
but when i went to mckinley that was
[ __ ] uh
we were a little bit more
not [ __ ] but we were a little just
on top of that they still had the pilot
program
the pilot program was designed for cuban
kids who came over on the boat and they
just couldn't break bust out of the
seventh grade
but if you were driving to the seventh
grade you signed up and they put you to
the pilot program i swear to god
george i swear to god [ __ ]
interesting george i swear to god you go
to you being the seventh grade with the
same [ __ ] he was in the seventh
grade two years ago all of a sudden
you're in the seventh grade
you're like what happened because in
those days you come from cuba in the
second grade and you picked up the
english but by the time the seventh
grade came we just [ __ ] confused you
it was too nice bro i'm not making this
[ __ ] up no i i was in special classes
they had the
elementary and stuff yeah they had the
pilot program so the pilot program
the rule was if you had sideburns
or if you drove your family to the
school because if you were 17 in spanish
in those days you already had a kid you
had a part-time job on the maqueta
cutting meat and [ __ ] those kids are
crying i mean i went bro when i was in
the eighth grade
i went to school with a cuban kid named
juan ali and he had already two chicks
pregnant
he had two babies in the eighth grade
and he was working for his father at a
gas station what grade was he supposed
to be in like he was supposed to be like
28. he had hair and [ __ ] he drove a
truck for his family but he was in the
eighth grade one ali disappeared
there was one particular kid his name
was louis zelda
and russo he was like one of those
russian looking cubans they called them
tall white dude yeah they hang with the
ali brothers juan alberto ali
juan was solid but alberta was a little
bit [ __ ] when they were like 13 12
they would go to these prostitution
houses in new york with their uncle
cuban dude and whenever juan would say
you ever see those comedy teams on tv
hey george what are you doing
boss i didn't know what was going on it
was the same relationship with his
brother
we'd be in the seventh grade and they'd
show up and they go what'd you do this
week oh i went to the movies what'd you
do i went to the circus what'd you do
one only me and my brother went to this
[ __ ] house over in the bronx they
suck your dick for ten dollars they wash
it dick in a bucket he would just look
at the [ __ ] brother he'd go see
that's all he would say
see
they were taking this [ __ ] kid into
the city to get his dick sucked
juan ali the worst thing was
good for him why not wanted alberto ali
juan was the sharp one the butter was a
little [ __ ] [ __ ]
he just he just followed the brother he
was like that brother they charged more
for him or than giggled no he didn't
have the chinese eye he wasn't [ __ ]
looking he was just two steps ahead of
the game i'm saying like he barely if he
didn't follow his brother he forget what
school was
he was one of those guys
but he would [ __ ] get lost
dog we lived right next to dura test not
me i hung out in that neighborhood but
dura test was where they made light
bulbs so every day after school we jump
into a garbage can and do a test
and we take the long light bulbs out and
the short ones and we beat each other up
george you go home all white about it
so i got on the roof one day it took
like a bucket of light bulbs and i got a
roof one day and i just thought of
throwing light bulbs off the roof right
wow
and i there was a rock on the floor and
i just threw it up not even thinking
right here
and i look over that's alberto the
[ __ ] one he's on the floor and he's
like
oh
man i hit him in the head he had a lump
but i hadn't busted open it was just
like one of those contusions that keeps
growing and you can see the pus at the
end we had to pick him up off the floor
and sure it was tremendous just to make
sure he was like that before you hit him
with a light bulb right oh yeah he was
missing a couple of [ __ ] all right
but i think he was in the pilot program
louis zaldival was in the pilot program
orlando saucedo another cuban kid that
throughout the whole class he would just
do this one he was just in the back and
go wow
that's it
every 10 minutes wow
the teacher would lift the head up and
go who's ever making the heavy breathing
please knock it off
all these dudes got left back like eight
times
and when they went to seventh grade
pilot program gone up to the high school
program and then they last a year
because it was all they couldn't they
couldn't deal with it
yes it's tough man i'm gonna get weird
turn the mic around so i can hear you
every day
13 13 1-2
[ __ ] those are the old days you got me
all sent to the awesome all those
characters you described it's funny the
the names you gave them the acronyms i
think it's called right is that the
right word
it translates directly to my generation
like all the descriptions of ed russo i
know he's between
five three
and six two he's a white guy
light hair light eyes you know like like
a spanish dude you know so i know what
type of character he also is tremendous
you know he was real cuban and there was
a teacher we have mr brown and mr brown
would raise his head up and go louis
zaldivar
and he was so cute and then he'd get
[ __ ] mad like that [ __ ]
saying my name wrong
and before he got into the pilot program
i showed him my own eyes i was getting a
peanut butter sandwich from the lunch
baby mrs sabatino
and i turned around and he was talking
to the principal lewis alderweight
and the principal told him to stop to
take him up to the office i'll never
forget his plan is that
and he grabbed lewis out of the buzz arm
and this guy pulled his arm off turned
around and just [ __ ] decked the
principal
the principal didn't go down but his
hair was all [ __ ] up he was walking
like as he rung his belt
and the principal said you're out of
here you're thrown out of he went up to
his office and locked the [ __ ] door
i never saw louis alderweireld again
until facebook like four years ago
but that
class we had a teacher
when i was in the eighth grade that was
the roughest school
like it wasn't rough as far as the
characters like there was a kid charlie
gizzy
and whenever a plane would go by he
would make believe he was shooting it
down
he would get on the desk
like there was a couple kids david in
fact david bishop i heard went back
after he graduated the eighth grade he
went to college no he went to high
school he went to the marines and he
came back to mckinley to shoot one of
the teachers
that normal dog we were some hardcore
dude dog that that you knew that
something wasn't gonna work out for yeah
we had people like ray canelo who was
solid
but one day we had this teacher
something happened bro we were knocking
out
substitutes by the day and i'm not
talking about striking them or hitting
not at all nobody ever looked at a thing
in those schools
we would torment them
yeah i was part of the
dog we used to go to shop right right
behind my school and steal hubba bubba
for lunch
we'd steal a six-pack a hubba bubba
what are you talking about oh my god
we'd stick hubba bubba in our mouth and
chew it while you were on [ __ ] on the
blackboard adding figures we'd all whip
a piece of hubba bubba your [ __ ] head
one day a janitor was coming in with a
ladder and we threw a hubba bubba at him
and they hit him right in the face and
almost knocked them over and he kept
saying somebody hit me with bubblegum
one guy goes what flavor thought we used
to torment
the people that came into that classroom
the day we [ __ ] them up the most was
we were all in there one day the
principal came in he's like i don't even
know why i'm doing this
because i don't even know what i'm doing
this he goes there's some guy here that
wants to talk to you
it's uh you know you sell chocolate for
kids or whatever he wants to talk to you
um i'm gonna give him 10 minutes of your
time please be courteous we were animals
in the 8th grade dog
this guy came in he's telling us about
these diseases that her kids and you
have to sell this chocolate and
it costs a million dollars to do the
therapy and [ __ ]
and the the problem with the kids is if
they get the disease they can only walk
three feet per every
10 minutes or something
and the guy goes does anybody have any
suggestions if you want to sell
chocolate
and this dude i'll never forget his name
is richie colombo
his haircut he basically was a poor
italian kid and his mother would just
cut in between here and put water on his
hair and by nine o'clock his hair would
just pop up even the teacher asked him
what would you call me here with a stick
of dynamite because his hair bro was
perfect down the middle
but not to take away from the story the
teacher said do you have any suggestions
and richie coleman goes let me ask you a
question
so what you're telling me is they take
three steps every 20 minutes
did you ever think of giving them roller
skates so that was it
the dude looked at his clothes this
briefcase
picked it up and walked right the [ __ ]
out of there that he be on the way out
he's like i heard you people are [ __ ]
animals
we were animals at that age bro we went
to philadelphia they made the mistake to
take us to philadelphia for the holidays
for the nutcracker suite
we lasted 20 minutes we took paper clips
with rubber bands and we started
whipping them at the [ __ ] players on
the stage and somebody got hit that's it
throw them a kill i couldn't kill
somebody
we had a good time in that class
cuban kids some crazy italians couple
jews you guys weren't allowed in field
trips standard
like you got your classroom
field trips wasn't an option for you
guys no we weren't good at field trips
everywhere we went we caused damages
yeah which is a good thing
what are you talking about the best
thing as a kid he was part of the live
the the group that was having a blast
yeah we're gonna have a good time we
have those barbecues and [ __ ]
what's the next six months what's the
next year what do you want
155 170 where you want to be in 170 170
pounds beautiful
yes sir
yes sir and you're you're getting right
you're you're in there in a good time
at a perfect opportunity the world is in
your [ __ ] you like tony montana 84
you know what i'm saying oh man the
world is yours right now it's all up to
you there's no more [ __ ] around what
i'm saying
these are sharp decisions and [ __ ] this
is like a war now you're playing that
game as a kid battleship d4 this is what
this became battleship this is why you
played battleship as a kid you know what
i'm saying i love it i love what you did
i love what you've been doing
i've been a fan for a long [ __ ] time
and
it's great to see that it's all coming
together
but it didn't come together overnight
you know what i'm saying
you earned everything and now you're
burping up a strong from that thai food
i wouldn't eat that [ __ ]
if they served it at the white house i'd
run the [ __ ] out of there the thai food
in california never pass it up i don't
know okay i used to go to that place
when i first moved here 20 years ago and
get the pad thai shrimp at night
it was tolerable i would take the
peanuts i don't want peanuts on my
[ __ ] noodles oh that's the best part
no no no i like the sprouts oh i take
that apart
that's how they mix with the peanuts
with the noodles
shrimp and [ __ ] that place that used to
be my name you guys are old school cuban
mentality where you like at a certain
weight there's no changing
i love that you're a ufc fighter and
then you like you left your thai food
outside of the office oh no i can't tell
her he knows i'll puke in here
i'll [ __ ] puke i can't that [ __ ] ever
and then i'll be on my nose for four
days
that's what kills me about all that type
of food that sticks in my [ __ ] nose
you know mcdonald's is great you were
going to mcdonald's bro
you got a big mac
it was it's [ __ ] great you ever eat
mcdonald's on a plane you ever smell
mcdonald's on a plane and ain't too
[ __ ] good my friend
and ain't too [ __ ] good that's what
i'm saying that's all i'm saying if this
was my house you could have brought it
over but in this office to leave thai
food in here you [ __ ] me up
anyway anyway [ __ ] me up in here i
couldn't come in here for a week and
have to peep this febreze to [ __ ] and it
wouldn't even be tonight that he you you
he'd smell it through the door right now
no you can't yes i can what do you smell
some type of food
i could smell it right now as we speak
i'm not insulting nobody or nobody's
food i'm just saying that
there's a string of food i can't even
[ __ ] smell
i can't even be in the same room one of
them being one of the most favorable
cuban foods there is yooka can't even be
in the same room i don't want to be in
the same [ __ ] thing [ __ ] if i sit
at your table put the yukon the other
side with me please because you don't
salt the [ __ ] out of me what all the way
down there all the way down there you
and you told me broccoli and i ordered
broccoli next to you in boston you
didn't say anything because i couldn't
[ __ ] smell it good thing you told me
that once i smell it then i'm gonna say
something can you please move the
[ __ ] broccoli
i went to a concert one time at the la
hollywood bowl whatever the [ __ ]
the whole time i sat there with a
headache i didn't know what it was bro
it smelled like [ __ ] something i
looked down to check out a box of
[ __ ] broccoli what i wanted to hit
him in the head who goes to a concert
he's [ __ ] broccoli what i'm saying
here's what i deal with this is what i
[ __ ] deal with this is my world my
friend
see that's how i can if you want to
torture that person go ahead and do that
the person who brings broccoli to a
concert please there's no listening but
you weren't suspecting people once you
bring broccoli to a concert
there's no help for you
you've passed the barrier reef i can't
[ __ ] help you there's no fun i can't
[ __ ] help you it's the point of no
return expose 87. you know what i'm
saying
what are you
crazy [ __ ] broccoli to a concert
that's the world we live in today and
people are getting some hot sauce
anything right ranch blue cheese nothing
marijuana that's all you bring to a
concert marijuana quaaludes
cocaine acid whatever you got you bring
to like your mother's pain medication
you don't give a [ __ ] you don't want to
say you don't want any snacks no i'll
get snacks later after the [ __ ]
concert
who takes me you know but they have
these outdoor concerts and that that's
what i was saying was like disco and i
went over to the hollywood bowl and
people put their blankets down and [ __ ]
this wasn't the cheap seats this was
like the good seats my wife worked that
but it was uh the lady had broccoli i
could not [ __ ] believe it
i cannot believe it that's cali in miami
they'll sneak in
so you know all types of stuff at the
movies
oh no i don't mind food at the movies a
good [ __ ] uh
oh please a nice little cuban sandwich
at the movies but you got to be selling
sitting with your homies because you can
smell the cuban sandwich too
see i got i got [ __ ] over at the
movies a couple weeks ago some guy had
nachos next to me and i i i used to be i
used to have a craving for those movie
theater nachos
no not have to sit next to it for 45
minutes i don't know how bad do they
smell oh they smell terra i'll tell you
what else i can't smell popcorn
popcorn dries me my wife likes popcorn
do you like do you mean popcorn do you
mean the butter or both i like popcorn
with butter a little bit of salt and a
lot of [ __ ] you got like spiderman
senses in your nose yeah
that's [ __ ] nice after i stopped
doing coke you put pepper on popcorn
that's crazy oh yeah no you don't
parmesan cheese little pepper parmesan
oh my god parmesan garlic parmesan a
little bit that's always hipster thing
you do with a little [ __ ] butter you
mix it in there [ __ ] good that's
popcorn not that [ __ ] dry like i'm in a
[ __ ] prison camp with no water i need
two gallons i gotta get up eight times
during the movie
don't put butter on it you better put
[ __ ] butter on that [ __ ] i'll
put on your side no put on the whole
[ __ ] thing because before i do it
right
but for the lady come here you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] to me
you put a little bucket under there you
hit it with a little butter in the
bottom
see these [ __ ] animals just put the
popcorn on top
and then they hit in the middle no no no
no no no no no no burn through the bag
you make lasagna you put [ __ ] on the
bottom don't you yeah same thing you put
a little butter on the bottom you dope
up that buckle a little bit get the
bucket ready for what's coming in there
oh you're getting the breakfast okay
then you hit the popcorn three four five
inches again a little bit of [ __ ]
butter a little bit of salt a little bit
of [ __ ] pep and a little bit of
garlic parmesan so you get in that
bottom level
okay you want to do it right why is
everybody got to be a [ __ ] animal
this was not taught to me this was not a
video that i watched this was not on
[ __ ] one of these cooking shows this
is something i figured out from sticking
my hand down there and looking for [ __ ]
and now you got an 18 [ __ ] napkins
and guess what you got to get up anyway
to go wash your hands unless you're a
[ __ ] filthy animal are you going to
watch that movie with sticky [ __ ]
hands the rest of the movie you get up
and wash your hands oh i bring extra
napkins right napkins yeah yeah but the
three napkins look at you look at you
you want to save trees you get the [ __ ]
out of here because i'm bringing eight
so i got a [ __ ] bucket i put butter
in that [ __ ] yeah then i put
popcorn on top of that then i hit it
with the garlic parmesan little pepper a
dash of salt and i hit it again with
that three four more inches then i have
a little butter a little salt again then
i dip it with two more inches and then
you but before you add those two inches
you stick like a [ __ ] straw in there
right from the count and you mix it up
good like
you know what i'm saying dog i'm telling
you this is how you do [ __ ] popcorn i
remember going to the movies because how
long did that take i'm just picturing
the order him placing the
order no no because you got to stop me
excuse me man can i talk to you for a
second
you know me and you we're americans
you're going to do this this was the
right way as americans this is how
americans do popcorn hit a nature butter
in there what are you saying hit the
button with no [ __ ] butter in there i
don't want no popcorn put an inch of
butter in there
now put the popcorn in three inches
now stop what you're doing give me the
popcorn
trick hit it with some butter please
boom before you do this you put a five
on the counter i mean i'm not a savage
you understand me now we're talking you
put a five on the count see but what do
you what are you gonna do now some a lot
of movie theaters the butter is
somewhere far away from the from where
they give you the popcorn yeah do they
wanna take a hike [ __ ] i'm giving you a
five you know what i'm saying
you get 10.50 an hour i'm throwing
another fin on you i'm a gentleman i
wouldn't tell her to do the special
unless before i even say that i put the
fin down i got listen we're going to go
to a little project here do you mind
here's a little fight i do it all the
[ __ ] time now because i don't want
[ __ ] the way they give it to me anymore
you ever do the popcorn at home
no no no no no my wife buys the bags and
[ __ ] she's like we're having pop movie
night now i gotta sit there and smell
this [ __ ] popcorn for 20 minutes i
gotta open up the back
door i hate all those smells bro i put
tabasco sauce on the popcorn what that's
not bad either but not tabasco sauce i
don't put any butter on my popcorn no i
know you don't why would you do
something like that
who needs butter
oh yeah yeah that's nice too
i throw some parmesan cheese on that
[ __ ] too parmesan cheese got no cap no
no carbs you could put a jar with that
[ __ ] in your box because it doesn't have
carbs doesn't mean you have to eat it
but it adds flavor with a little bit of
[ __ ] pepper and a little bit of
[ __ ] butter come on lee i don't know
yeah
[ __ ] i'm the worst dud in the world and
i even knew that you want to eat
non-buttered popcorn well no you're the
one who always talks about tradition
this yeah there's no tradition of none
by the popcorn unless you're a prisoner
watching a movie on movie night i put i
can put a little only people would only
pop butter on popcorn this convicts on
[ __ ] friday night when you gotta
watch pt 209 with no butter on your
popcorn after three kernels you're like
i can't take this no more i'd rather do
an extra year than eat this [ __ ] dry
[ __ ] popcorn that's what i'm talking
about but what about parmesan cheese
parmesan cheese but you still gotta have
the butter in there right when you make
the tortellini oh yeah you put butter in
there you also throw some parmesan
cheese in there and some black pepper
that's the flavor lee you want to dope
up everything in this [ __ ] world you
can't eat it like they give it to you if
not you end up like the rest of these
mutts
you gotta take the time it takes two
minutes and a little bit of kindness to
ask the girl at the movie theater listen
can we do this a little [ __ ]
different i'm gonna teach you some
wisdom wisdom
two inches of butter popcorn
pop you go in there you got no problems
you lit you enjoying your movie
the razor that's on [ __ ] and they're
in the what do you call it when the
pictures are in the back pitching
warming up
what is it
no no pan they're in the bullpen warming
up right where you're eating your
popcorn who's better than you you got
that buttery popcorn you got some
raisins you got all the chocolate
covered ones
the only thing i'm going to show up with
just raisins what am i the guy who came
with [ __ ] broccoli
yeah i was thinking that who shows up
with raisins with no
the same people showed up to the concert
with broccoli
with broccoli did they have a sauce for
it hot sauce anything or was just
broccoli these poor people leave them
alone
just raw broccoli raw broccoli and they
no but they have branch sauce they have
blue cheese listen they had something
the best naked i had was poison to dip
it that's their best bet all right all
right it doesn't really matter they have
blue cheese or rance
who shows up with [ __ ] rocks it's
crazy it's insane that you showed up
with broccoli period but i just want to
see how much crazier they were because
if you show up with a sauce
okay maybe it doesn't really make sense
but whatever but if you show up with no
sauce you're a complete savage you're
just eating broccoli like to survive
that's crazy you know any of these
people that we showed with broccoli
they're probably uh
they're on a [ __ ] certain diet to
impress their friends that's great
that's crazy that's what they you know
they're on something just broccoli
that's crazy
i don't have time for that manager you
don't know
if you're gonna get down and get done
you're gonna contact the smoke dope and
eat cheeseburgers whatever the [ __ ] they
give you i don't know what the name is
have food it can't tell you i don't
[ __ ] know i never went to a concert
deed i was all messed up
doing drugs i don't know time to either
the [ __ ] concert anyway i'm gonna eat
in a [ __ ] concert and jump up and
down and get nachos on my shirt
that's what i was wondering i was
wondering if they have they had like
vegetables for sale at the hollywood
bowl or she brought them from home she
brought them in one of those raps
containers oh no
the ones that have everything in it but
sometimes you could just buy the
broccoli she just bought the broccoli
i've seen uh you've seen that and it's
[ __ ] huge oh my god so she opened the
tub and i'm like what's that [ __ ]
odor
i've seen i've seen periscopes of girls
doing that on planes like with like
vegetables they bring snacks for planes
you you have no idea how bad food if you
really you know
everybody walks around making them
believe they really [ __ ] cat
if they may believe they really can't
care about that no you don't because you
wouldn't do certain [ __ ] if you've ever
smelt mcdonald's on a plane you're never
sure you know what do me a favor bro
unless they sell that food on the plane
that don't stink don't bring your own
[ __ ] food
when i fly out in miami i'd buy 20 cuban
sandwiches
i tell them not to cook them
i put them in my overnight compartment
nobody even knows like a doctor i put it
right next to my sleep apnea machine a
bag of [ __ ] cuban sandwiches now if i
was to cook them and put them on the
plane they'd have to make a detour in
detroit because the plane would stick
like [ __ ] garlic
so i would never do that i would never
do something like that in a [ __ ]
plant but people don't give a [ __ ]
they bring those nasty sandwiches on the
plane and [ __ ]
mcdonald's smells terrible on the planet
curry smells terrible on the planet like
i love curry you can't do that
like strong curry
if i'm on a plane i ate a couple edibles
and you sit next to me with curry it's a
problem
i'm going to bring the buzz and make up
for lies and everything but i heard you
on the phone talking about [ __ ]
your cousin khabib you'll meet him at
the airport i will straight to that oh
you sit next to me with hummus
all that [ __ ] i will downline once
on the plane though i will be [ __ ]
henry hill i will dial you the [ __ ] out
and tell him i just hurry i smell
cigarettes on you i smell [ __ ] uh
what's that [ __ ] you know i mean not
pedophile juice uranium i smell uranium
i make up story you sure i need more i
got no time for it i thought you got a
plane in my area with hummus
i'm gonna report you to the authorities
you understand me
you're going to find the air marshal
they give they give me a virgin gives
you a hummus yeah american i think
i don't think american ever gave me
hummus i know virgin gives me [ __ ]
hummus
what do you do
i just don't even open it i tell her to
take it off my plate please
because they give you a menu on virgin
and they'll say hummus i'll tell listen
forget the chips and the hummus alone
really you don't want them no i don't
want them and i suggest you don't have
it
i look at the lady next time i suggest
you don't have me because i'm gonna pee
really i can't take it you eat the
hummus i'm gonna puke after six [ __ ]
minutes i just had a big breakfast
they don't eat the [ __ ] hummus i tell
people right next to me right there i
don't give a [ __ ] you're not eating that
[ __ ] don't even [ __ ] think about it
i love it it's crazy
oh my god
i don't like these [ __ ] that
walk around with a half cup of coffee
either drink your [ __ ] coffee and
finish it let's go on delay these
[ __ ] that get on the plane with
a half cup of coffee then they fall
asleep and i'm just staring at the cup
the whole time and suspect
after you fall asleep next to me i throw
the coffee cup on come here for a second
take that coffee i don't even touch the
fingerprints i don't i hate dead coffee
get that [ __ ] away from me all together
have you ever let someone spill
something on you on a plane yes no you
have not yes
coffee
i think i [ __ ] hate coffee i spilt it
on me and i had like a three hour delay
i stumped like [ __ ] coffee and i was
furious i'd stay stained my [ __ ]
jeans oh no was it cold coffee
it was yeah they put it on the [ __ ]
thing [ __ ] i hate coffee like
that i like i get my coffee i drink it
pink pan by the way thank you for
teaching my family how to make cumin
coffee
we've been drinking that [ __ ] a lot
lately i had to stop because of the
sugar content too much sugar fungus
was sugar on a daily basis that's good
for a little treat down there but yeah
that was strong that was
good
i could drink one of those right now no
you can't yes i can and be asleep in a
half hour i will smoke a joint and eat a
nicotine gum i'll be another planet with
that coffee jack that's that cuban
coffee once that nicotine gum
gets that cancer sugar you're [ __ ]
flying jack that's that's his cancer
high right there
george mazdaval what are you [ __ ]
nuts or what look at you rocking and
rolling looking good
looking healthy god bless you brother
you're on your way this is it you worked
hard for this all your life it's so
weird
when the decision is right in front of
you now it's all up to you now
just sir
what are you doing one of my marines are
doing something like that yes sir me
what do you think lisa how are you doing
buddy
how's the blue apron diet what's been
going on over there it's good and i
actually uh
i actually my dad's gonna try it it's uh
he's pretty excited about it
i'd say it's been going great i love we
just finished our last one we did uh
paula made tacos the other night tacos
look at that what flavor were they uh
they were just be they were uh just beef
tacos and they had a little radish uh
salad on top
uh and then she made a little sweet but
there was a little sweet potato
mixture uh with fries and like a little
bit of cheese actually it was nice
very nice see yeah you miss your wife's
cooking oh it reminds me
[ __ ] you
you can't wait to go
can't wait to get home
overall
the latin food i miss it very very much
you know being in colorado i ate a lot
of good clean food like broccoli and
carrots
steak potato things like that on a daily
basis
now when i get back i'm just going to
eat the usual diet how many times you've
been to colorado before this for
training um
like three other times what do you think
of colorado you know your heart love it
love it
i love it it's one of my favorite places
in the country
do you feel different when you how high
up have you gone
what's the highest city you've been
oh you wouldn't fail you were in
vancouver i was in vail skiing yeah and
breckenridge
um i did the highest peaks here in those
mountains so whatever it was
i don't remember the numbers but it was
pretty high like 13 12 000. you feel
different when you're in those mountains
[ __ ] yeah man it's a different feeling
it's different there even the cold feels
different hell yeah
you know like
clear hey it changed my life bro when i
went to colorado i was blown the [ __ ]
away i thought new york city was this
magical city and like
there's no magic in buildings bro
you know when you go to colorado and you
look around and once you go away from
denver
you know man
i'm thinking about it
it's always open you know
i'm already comfortable i was there for
15 years i'm comfortable i can be there
the winter don't kill me there ain't no
[ __ ] winter
ain't no winter
you might as well other than aspen i
used to shovel snow while in the
snowmass village
i liked it
it's not that bad i've had worse winters
in [ __ ] jersey in new york city than
i had in colorado bro
it's no there's no humidity in the snow
so it doesn't weight dick
that east coast snow they got last week
people were dying that [ __ ] weighs 22
[ __ ] pounds every school yeah because
it's moisture in there that's your
motherly oh yeah she was really [ __ ]
a lot it's really wet that snow back
then colorado like i said to you this
week right now and next week is when
they do a bikini finals
and people
ski and snowmass with a bikini on and
they have to do a loop-de-loop and land
in a [ __ ] pool well who skis with a
[ __ ] bikini on it's because the low
humidity in the water i guess and people
got a tremendous suntan as you noticed
yeah it's like going to [ __ ] hawaii
going uh yeah i'm going next week to
tahoe i can't [ __ ] wait man well
uh we we spoke on the last podcast that
you were going to denver a month early
for a reason with your giving with your
coaches do you think that had any effect
how did you think that paid off no it
definitely paid off i went to colorado
springs
which is uh higher than um denver
we i did i was there for about three
weeks and then uh the last week of
of the fight i went to denver
and what was your cuban training consist
of when you were in colorado springs
what was there was there any breathing
techniques was there really breathing
exercises i got the i got the book
dropping in two weeks if the book
dropped i got the book dropping if you
get it online it's cheaper ten percent
off
got the book dropping two weeks barnes
and nobles walmart
what's the name of the book i'm [ __ ]
with you oh okay no you never know no
i'm joking man not um the cubans just
believe
train hard year round you know and
that's what we did we didn't really do
nothing different you know i just went
there for a month to get acclimated to
the air
so uh i mean that that's as far as i
could have
they told me five weeks before so in
about a week i organized my training
camp where i was gonna be and everything
and then i took out for
for a month exactly to to colorado
and i thought it had one more time tapes
and [ __ ] how did your running feel oh it
sucked in the beginning
how long did you go before you had to
stop and get a little dizzy did you ever
get dizzy of course that's amazing yeah
it's a different game the first two days
it wasn't that bad i was like i'm in
pretty good shape and i have been
sleeping in the elevation town already
for like
a couple weeks because i thought i was
going to fight in mexico november 5th so
i still had that 10 and i used it for
about six weeks so i thought oh maybe
the tent did help
by the third fourth and fifth day my
body crashed like bad like my first day
back in training it took me up to my
11th and 12th day my body started coming
back into it
by day number
21 is that when my body was already like
acclimated you know and it's crazy how
that uh
that chemistry that happens in your body
happens and it's it's a science to it
you know
i had a friend that had a way he was a
bicycle guy and this was
way this is 84. he wasn't doing anything
this is way before lance armstrong
showed up with his bag of [ __ ]
goodies
but he would go up there is new zealand
high is that a high altitude new zealand
uh let me check and i lived in new
zealand and then he'd come out to aspen
and he'd get a job with his dude named
chip chilton masonry and that would be
his hot carry
for the summer
at the end of the summer chip gave you a
bonus and he gave you skis or something
because he was a real
world-class skier his trade was he was a
mason guy
so this guy used to be like a bicycle
guy and i thought he just rode his bike
in on me though i don't ask questions he
had the helmet and [ __ ] and he had the
whole ghee the whole bicycle rider's
ghee with the tight pants and [ __ ] just
so happened this guy was a badass in
that sport
and i asked him how he got acclimated he
was talking about every week he would
draw blood
because that's basically what you're
doing right you're just making more red
blood cells yeah
so to acclimate quicker and stronger
he would take blood out so he would have
to double his load he said
in the force 14 to 20 days he said it
was hard
but after that it just kicked and
doubled like he felt it and then two or
three weeks after that he was where he
was at you know
it's just uh you know people experiment
whatever the [ __ ] they do no there's
there's plenty of theories i think um
from
anywhere from three to six months is
when you get the full benefits already
depending on the person and i've read a
lot of different studies
the cubans believe that after like uh 21
days you're already good the american
school from what i've heard they believe
that at 21 days you start to get
acclimated and up to six months you can
get all the benefits
of somebody that's that's been living
there for like 10 years would you
consider just doing a training camp yeah
that one for everybody eight weeks for
sure i i fell in love with colorado i
know they're upset in denver but that's
a beautiful state over there i love that
i'm considering moving and everything
just to hold my training camps over
there eight weeks out ten weeks out just
because of the altitude get those
benefits you know and you want to ski
and i want to ski
that's uh that's perfect
yeah training scheme i don't know how
often i'll be skiing because i could get
hurt but at least twice a week for sure
listen man i used to ski a lot
and knock on wood
i did three seasons of you know getting
up
going to bed at six from snorton and
getting up at nine taking the shower
drinking [ __ ] orange juice and
getting on those skis
and i'll tell you what
i gotta knock on wood and tell you not a
thing
how did i was a wild man bro because i
saw people i had a bunch of friends
there from mankato minnesota
these dudes were dead devils
and every three weeks you'd see one of
them in a [ __ ] cast
so when i'd see him up on the mountain
wherever they told me to go i'd avoid
those [ __ ] i always stayed on
the medium whatever the medium was i
don't remember now it's been 20 years
and i would do my three or four runs and
once in a while i'd get cocky it's the
people who would ski off
whatever they call that backcountry
backcountry and all those guys
that's where you cause avalanches
that's where all that [ __ ] goes down
it's cute
but it really happens that's what you
caused all the avalanches so i always
just kept to myself i took falls
i took falls and i'm telling you me and
my roommate
we we hit the bag in those days we used
to lift weights and in the mornings we
go [ __ ] skiing
and not one of us no knee injuries no
nothing if you bend your legs right and
stuff and keep your knees together and
one stop and or the plow stop and stuff
unless you start doing those jumps and
when that tip gets caught that's when
your knees start going bro that's why
even at that age of 21 i wasn't johnny
surfer in fact there were times where
you pick up some momentum jack
you're going a little faster than what
you anticipated when you're skiing
sometimes after like two or three runs
you get your breathing up yeah and
you're flying down that hill and you
scare yourself i used to scare myself
and make myself slow down and go into
the side and start all over again or i'd
start cutting and weaving i don't know
what the expressions are now i'm sorry
people but
listen i never got hurt like that if you
play the game right of skiing
and go on the medium range and just say
to yourself i'm doing four runs as part
of my training
this yeah i'm gonna do four runs on the
last one to throw my skis in the [ __ ]
thing and go somewhere else and run for
an hour and a half and let's warm up the
knees like because you're like this
you're really [ __ ] warming up you're
[ __ ] going for it jack yeah
it's a great workout you know when you
get to the bottom of the hill you're
sweating especially under that [ __ ]
that sucks
i can't handle it yeah i'm still
learning i bet for the i bet for the
people at home they're listening talking
to me about skiing i used to ski the
first time i ski they put 185s on me bro
it's probably completely different now
then i went up to 205s or some [ __ ] and
i was going out there every day and i
loved it
and then i realized [ __ ] game in the
morning
the drug dealers would get up early and
ski
in those days so i'd [ __ ] shovel the
snow watch them leave and then
burglarize their house by the time they
got back for lunch i already had an
ounce of coke in my pocket they're up
there ha ha and [ __ ] them you got to be
guarding the stash if you're a coke
dealer you've got time to ski i'm saying
leave grandma at the house do something
just don't leave the house [ __ ] empty
and then go skiing after you bro after
you did that well this was before i left
in 83 i was burning horizon all the drug
deals because i knew i was leaving so i
would ski some days
then i skied all of january and i left
february first
once i knew the cops were watching me i
said [ __ ] i just ski every day
what are you gonna do george mazda wrote
i see big things my friend
you got to start yakking now i'm calling
these [ __ ] out and tell them to
suck your dick and call you shorty you
know what i'm saying
it's all over now this is the new game
now this isn't one game they don't wanna
fight you don't understand
they don't want to fight maya doesn't
want to fight
magny all of a sudden got injured
and uh
i just i can't get a fight right now i'm
i won the top five guy
and i want to get in there soon you know
i want to get the notice
nobody's
stepping up you know
sit tight my friends i'm sitting tight
shit's gonna go down something's gonna
happen something's gonna happen yeah
especially at the 170 shit's gonna get
rocked up there pretty soon yeah or 155
those two are gonna be interesting to
watch the next [ __ ] year or two
what are you gonna do lee what do you
got going on this week i got [ __ ]
valentine's day of flappers
i got the ice house with the boogaloo
man rogan and some crew
and thursday i'm doing the store with
[ __ ] uh
skyler stone
and then next week i'm in minneapolis
it's that simple very nice i'm at the
house of comedy from the 23rd or 24th to
the 26th you know me dawg stick around
what do you got going on
that's the grime right there bro what's
that
you you got a grind right there but i
spaced myself you follow me that's what
doesn't kill me if i went out every week
i wouldn't be the same human being
that's rough right there that's fine so
i space myself i give everybody a little
bit of attention everybody gets a little
loving the family the wife
lee you know
when do i get loving
when you get loved look at your eyeballs
in the mirror [ __ ] sucker if i don't
love you look at your eyeballs who do
you think gives you that loving those
eyeballs that makes them read two nights
a week
uncle joey why because i care for you
absolutely right i could be giving you
your susquehanna weed like giving you a
bad [ __ ] for your lungs you don't do
that at all i could be giving you bogus
[ __ ] acid that's some puerto rican
made in this basement no i give you this
[ __ ] the kid's almost gonna blow up the
basement with this kid shows up he's got
three fingers he's done the work you
understand me let me get the sheets of
paper you're sitting there like buddha
joe
i got [ __ ] uh
did you eat that rice krispie tell
anybody that rice crisp rice krispies
delicious and [ __ ] nutritious and i
gotta tell you something vegan
oh yeah yeah i don't know
gmo
no this is real deal but i don't [ __ ]
around over there at uh
whatever that company is i ate that 100
milligram
thing
that my wife left
i played with mercy for a little while
she said she wanted to watch moana
i said you got to watch in your room she
goes okay you gotta tell me to knock him
anyway she went in there i started
scrolling through the channels and there
was a movie on lifetime
i tell you about this i don't think so
about a girl that goes to duke
university she owes
six thousand dollars a semester so she
becomes a porn actress
i heard i heard i heard about that girl
in life yeah and she went on cnn and she
went on
the point is i don't ever watch nothing
like that it was that 100 milligram
[ __ ] rice krispie treat
that made me sit there like an animal
and watch that stupid lifetime [ __ ]
movie so it's not a bad [ __ ] edible
that thing
what lee what how long of a movie is it
it was probably two hours that i would
have killed myself somewhere along the
line thank god i turned it off after the
15 minutes oh she was cute she was
really cute and she was going on cnn
they they called her at school some kid
some little chinese kid that was a
friend
came up to and asked if she was a porn
star they did a pinky swear you know
these [ __ ] chinese people around me
he ratted this [ __ ] poor little young
girl out the college started throwing
[ __ ] bottles at her and she would
walk by dormitories and they would throw
boxes of garbage at her
and then uh they wrote a school column
paper and then then she went on cnn to
say she was justifying young women then
she won an award at the [ __ ] porno
awards
and she went home her parents hated it
it's the same type of diverse life but
she didn't do drugs she didn't become a
dick sucker
she held on to her you know what i'm
saying the point of the story is that's
how high i was that i watched that
stupid [ __ ] movie for at least 20 30
minutes
and i kept switching back to it that's
what really [ __ ] had me because i
actually gave a [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying you got conviction yeah i was
watching that and something else i don't
know what the [ __ ] it was but anyway who
gives a [ __ ]
well obviously you're gonna sit there
like buddha joe and not talk to me more
no i'm i love talking teacher must teach
everything all right lee eyeballs
they're on [ __ ] fire tonight oh my
god you don't even know what got you if
it was the transmission fluid or it was
the [ __ ] i'm just happy that we ate
all the little lunas
at sunset
herbal and it it made my day when i went
there and there was no lulu no we ate
literally all of them he had nothing for
us tonight he even looked at me he goes
i got this and he goes take some stars
that's gonna get you but tomorrow we
pick up the shipment of stars this is
the one that killed [ __ ] cellular
crews and i'm saying
this is the shipment that kills sally
cruz tomorrow
we got some brownies in this small i got
some brownies right in there right now
tonight you go home eat a brownie put
whipped cream on it put in the nuger to
get the thc alive and kicking that
[ __ ] tonight get room service to
bring you some ice cream
that's how you eat the thc brownie again
these [ __ ] don't know how to
eat they go to a weed store they take
one of those cold brownies you need them
they taste like 10 dead dicks that's not
how you eat a brownie you take that
[ __ ] brownie you take it home you
nuke that thing for like 10 seconds and
then you get some ice cream and put it
on top and it naturally melts the ice
cream but the nuka helps it it gives it
a momentum then you put a little whipped
cream on that [ __ ] mixed with
the thing with the brownie it's a
different game though you think you're a
dairy queen lee it's a warm bun instead
of a cold piece of [ __ ]
all due respect to everyone who makes
edibles
it tastes like dairy queen until you get
down to the brownie and there's a hard
it's just a heart hot now just a hot
hard brownie not if you do it the right
way you take the [ __ ] ice cream you
smear it around the brownie then you mix
it all up together you know what i'm
saying you gotta dope up the brownie
[ __ ] lee
that thing you said like you said i
lived through george mazda i put the
cuban and everything you gotta do
something you gotta mix the [ __ ]
thing everybody in l.a if you go to l.a
if you go to hollywood tonight and
you're hungry at 1 o'clock they're going
to tell you to go to fat cells
fat towels makes a good sandwich but
it's not my style they make a sandwich
and they just throw ham fries or those
skinny [ __ ] fries on it and they
close the sandwich and they give it to
you i don't like that [ __ ] when i eat
[ __ ] french fries on the sandwich you
gotta cook whatever the [ __ ] you cooking
with those potatoes
so the flavor goes into it then when i'm
the [ __ ] thing
i'm pretty high today i gotta stop
talking
let me read our sponsors and i'll get
you [ __ ] out of here lee let me
talk to you about something on the up
and up here
what do you think
of your uh distilled dst ld jeans and
shirt tell me the truth i love them they
look great they
look they're very they're uh a very
they have very high quality products
that i i don't have i have i had a
little nothing i've never had anything
as nice as these jeans the the raw denim
i'm getting them uh shortened right now
because i have short legs i'm very sorry
but i'll bring them in next week and um
i also got a polo shirt i haven't i have
to try it on it's a uh
it's a beautiful shirt i hope it fits
and it it's uh the shipping was super
fast the site's beautiful i it it looks
uh
i'm just excited to wear it i've never
had jeans these nice
well it's hard to find the perfect pair
of jeans i mean you don't want to break
the bank
but you need something that lasts the
problem with jeans is a really good pair
cost two or three hundred dollars easily
and those are the bargain brands that
just fall apart or look terrible
dstld pronounced distilled offers luxury
grade denim at affordable price genes
that would normally cost you hundreds
dog
dstld has started at just 75
they utilize the same fabrics factories
and wash houses as the best known brands
and designers while skipping the markups
and the middleman the result pure
unadulterated denim without the retail
runaround just go to
dstld.com again
dstld.com
again
and see where the minimalist design
meets maximum comfort the guarantee
they fit they'll ship them to you for
free and give you free returns until you
find the perfect pair all right right
there dstld has been featured in forbes
time gq vogue
dstld is the only place in the us
you can get quality denim for this price
point period
go to dstld.com
joey right now and get 10 off your first
pair you're gonna love them they look
great on lee he's going to be a sexy
savage again that's ds
d again t s d s
t l d dot com
slash joey for 10
off your order right now five letters
write them down d
s
t
l d that's the company slash joey get 10
percent off who's better than you
[ __ ] all right
again
it's valentine's day you don't want to
[ __ ] around i mean you know
anyway
indochino you want to look good
you're wearing these [ __ ] up suits
you go to [ __ ] in one of these stores
the jacket is the wrong color the pants
let me explain something to you you go
on the website you make an appointment
you go to the store for me i went to the
place in beverly hills
they measure you they measure your check
they measure everything your feet
everything
they show you the lining of the coat
they show you the coat the material
you're ready to go within three weeks
you get a call you go back down there
and you pick it up it's that simple
the suits are tremendous
the quality is unparalleled and i gotta
tell you something even if a fat dude
like me the suit looks pretty good all
right
every man looks better in the suit right
you go out to vegas next week for march
3rd fight you're going to have a
tremendous [ __ ] suit on why
because you're george mazdaval what are
you [ __ ] nuts or what 20 like no
parole in the altitude
indochino is making it easy to get a
perfectly tailored suit an incredible
price you can choose from hundreds of
top quality fabrics
and personalize your suit just the way
you want it whether it works
whether it's for work a wedding or
another special occasion indochino has
suited up hundreds of thousands of men
and are now the largest made-to-measure
menswear brand in the world how it works
you visit the showroom or shop online at
indochino.com right now you pick your
fabric you choose your customations from
lapels to jacket linings you submit your
measurements you place your order wait
for it to arrive and in a few weeks
ba-boom you got a new suit you're
looking good you're feeling good and
who's better than you low self-esteem is
gone you can look in the mirror and go
who's the baddest [ __ ] i know me
so do yourself a favor this week my
listeners can get any premium indochino
suit for 389 at indochino.com
slash church at checkout again not 50
off the regular price
for made to measure premium suits you're
gonna look good guys plus shipping free
that's indochino.com
promo code church chur ch for any
premium suit for 389
and free shipping incredible deal for
the suit that will fit you better than
anything off the rack could ever do also
it's valentine's day i'm giving you one
more shot
don't fight the crowds with a big night
out don't worry about making
reservations turn your home into a
luxury spa with private massage with
seals all right here's an idea make
valentine's easy get a couple's massage
and a licensed massage therapist from
zeals here's an easy way to win over
valentine's day bring her over
have a nice meal and afterward your
masseuse comes over just go to zeel.com
or on zeal's
phone or android.zeal
spelled z e e
z e e l
dot com and select from top local
license pre-screen massage
therapist all right choose your favorite
technique gender preference time and
location
cecile will send over one of the 8 000
licensed massage therapists with a
massage table music and supplies to give
you a five star massage do me a favor
for valentine's day to help you get
started our listeners will get 25
off their first massage by using promo
code church at checkout c-h-u-r-c-h
that's zeal spell
z-e-e-l.com and then make sure to click
add promo code and check out the used
code church right now go to zeel.com or
the zeal's iphone android app and enter
promo code church and check out to get
25
off your first
in-home massage on demand all right i
love you guys i want to thank endochino
i want to thank dstld
zeal and i also want to thank my little
brother george mazdaval for coming on
the show
[ __ ] happens you know i love you but i'm
very proud of you i'm very proud you
came on tonight
and i'm very [ __ ] excited to find out
who your next victim is you know what
i'm saying that's how i roll i'm so
[ __ ] pumped man i can't wait
it's uh
it's depressing for me when i don't have
a fight i i get like anxious and stuff
you know i i gotta have something to
look forward to and um
my my eyes everything is only on the
belt you know i'm staying in tip-top
shape so whoever whoever it is it gets
the call i'm ready for
god bless you my brother lee hit it
[ __ ] i'll see you guys wednesday
night
don't forget about me stay black i'll
see you next weekend
at the house
of comedy
at the mall of america thursday friday
saturday one show thursday to friday to
saturday see you [ __ ] down i
love you have a great week